ahora veamos con mayor detalle a la
cóclea y al oído interno
voy a dibujar una cóclea aquí que parece
caracol y ahora vamos a desenrollar lo
si lo hacemos queda algo como esto
esto es una cóclea plana aquí está el
pequeño hueso que habíamos mencionado el
estribo y el estribo está conectado a
otros dos huesos y a la membrana
timpánica básicamente se mueve de un
lado a otro con la misma frecuencia que
la onda sonora que hace vibrar a la
membrana timpánica el estribo está
conectado con esta membrana ovalada que
se llama ventana oval el estribo empuja
la ventana de un lado a otro conforme
éste también se mueve cuando la ventana
oval se mueve hacia adentro empuja el
fluido que se encuentra dentro de la
cóclea este es el fluido todo lo largo
de la cóclea y de regreso y como
mencioné antes la razón por la que el
fluido se mueve en esta dirección es
porque hay una estructura en medio que
llamamos el órgano de corti este órgano
divide a la cóclea en dos de manera que
el fluido solo puede ir en ésta
en ambos sentidos cuando el fluido llega
a este lado se encuentra con una
membrana circular que se llama ventana
redonda y esta ventana redonda es
empujada hacia afuera por el fluido que
la comprime así que tenemos fluido que
va y viene
alrededor del órgano de corte ahora
vamos a ver un corte transversal del
órgano de corte para poder comprender
cómo el movimiento de este fluido se
convierte en sonido si hiciéramos un
corte transversal de esto veríamos algo
así aquí hay una membrana superior y una
membrana inferior donde tenemos estas
células vellosas con estos extremos que
parecen aletas de tiburón en la parte de
arriba
conforme el fluido alrededor del órgano
de corti empuja hacia abajo esta
membrana superior y hacia arriba la
membrana inferior aquí pueden imaginarse
cómo se mueve este fluido y esta presión
en las membranas hacia arriba y abajo
provoca que las células vellosas se
muevan de un lado a otro que vibren
podemos hacer un acercamiento a una de
estas células vellosas para verla con
mayor detalle
las células vellosas se ven más o menos
así con esta parte que parece aleta de
tiburón aquí arriba la parte de aleta de
tiburón de hecho está formada por stereo
cilios que parecen pelitos pero
realmente son un grupo de filamentos de
hecho voy a dibujar un acercamiento para
que los veamos mejor los estéreo cilios
lucen así cada uno de estos filamentos
es un estéreo silió estos filamentos se
encuentran unidos entre sí y forman esta
estructura cada uno de ellos está
conectado con los demás mediante estas
estructuras que parecen resortes
llamadas puentes apical es estas unen
las puntas de los estéreo cilios ahora
veamos un acercamiento a la punta de
este estéreo silió se ve más o menos así
aquí está una unión de punta que llega a
él que parece un resorte y de hecho no
está conectado directamente al estéreo
cilio sino que está conectado a la
compuerta de un canal de potasio aquí
estoy dibujando la compuerta de este
canal de potasio y conforme estos
estéreo cilios son empujados de un lado
a otro por el movimiento del fluido
dentro de la cóclea
van a estirar este resorte imaginemos
que esta unión de la punta es estirada
va a lucir más o menos así y conforme se
estira va a abrir la compuerta de este
canal de potasio cuando esta compuerta
se abre puede entrar a la célula el
potasio que hay afuera básicamente hay
potasio flotando por acá y va a entrar a
la célula también hay otros canales que
son canales de calcio que son activados
cuando el potasio entra en la célula por
lo que ahora también tendremos calcio
flotando adentro de la célula la entrada
de potasio y calcio a la célula hace que
se dispare un potencial de acción lo que
estimula a otra célula que se conoce
como célula de ganglio espiral la que a
su vez activa a otra célula que es parte
del nervio auditivo que luego llega al
cerebro esto es lo que sucede cuando una
onda sonora llega al oído y es
transmitida como impulso nervioso
mediante estas células vellosas